in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for June 18th, on which we commemorate the Holy Martyr
Leontios.
On the 18th of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Martyr Leontios and his companions,
Epatos and Theodolos.
Saint Leontios served in the Roman army during the reign of Vespation in about 69-70.
And distinguished himself for his bravery, while garrisoned in Tripoli in Phoenicia, he would
distribute army provisions to the poor, and hid neither his faith in Christ nor his condemnation
of idolatry.
His reputation came to the ears of Adrian, the governor of Phoenicia, who was a fervent
idol worshiper, and who had obtained from the emperor license to put the disciples of Christ
to death.
He sent a detachment of soldiers to Tripoli, led by the Tribune Epatos, or Epatos, with
a mission to arrest Leontios and guard him until he himself arrived in the city.
On nearing the city, Epatos was seized by a high fever, and that night an angel appeared
to him and said, if you wish to be healed, you must invoke the God of Leontios three times.
And the resplendent figure then disappeared.
Epatos did as he was directed and was immediately healed.
The next day, Epatos went to the city in the company of another soldier named Theodolos.
They encountered Leontios who greeted them cordially and presented himself as the friend of
the man they were seeking.
He then invited them to his house, and after lavishing splendid hospitality on them, revealed
that he was, in fact, Leontios, the soldier of Christ.
Epatos and Theodolos fell at his feet and begged him to deliver them from the impurity of idolatry
and to unite them to Christ.
When Leontios prayed for them, a cloud appeared in the sky, giving forth the water necessary
for their baptism.
After having been so illumined, they walked into the center of the city, dressed in their
white baptismal robes, and holding candles in their hands.
The pagans were up in arms at such a spectacle, and two days later, when Adrian arrived in
Tripoli, he had them arrested and imprisoned.
During the day, Leontios exhorted his companions to endure with joy the trials through which
they would obtain eternal life, and during the night they prayed and sang Psalms together.
In the morning they were taken to the tribunal to appear before Adrian.
Leontios declared that he was a son of the true light, which nothing could oppose, and
the soldier of Christ.
The magistrate in exasperation ordered that his bones be broken with rods, but the saint
remained unwavering and was finally returned to prison.
Adrian then summoned Epatos and Theodolos and asked why they had suddenly betrayed their
emperor.
Their reply was that they were henceforth enrolled in the army of the king of heaven and
that nothing in the world could make them return to the vain worship of idols.
Epatos was then tied to an iron frame to be burned alive, while Theodolos was struck repeatedly
with sword blows.
During this torture, no cry escaped from the lips of the two saints, except for, Lord,
of mercy.
Adrian then ordered that they be beheaded.
During a second interrogation they threatened to subject Leontios to the same tortures as
those of his companions, but he replied that the tortures were their crown, and the guarantee
of their eternal victory.
He was stretched out on the ground and beaten with rods by four soldiers, while a herald
was proclaiming, this is how those who rebel against the emperor and our gods are punished.
The saint cried out, You may well destroy my body, but you will not succeed in conquering
my soul.
He was burned but remained silent, his eyes raised to heaven in prayer.
The tyrant then ordered that he be suspended upside down and beaten, after a heavy stone
had been tied around his neck.
After this torture, he was sent back to prison.
During the night, while he was giving thanks to God, an angel came to comfort him and to
encourage him to fight the good fight until the end.
The next day the saint displayed the same resolution in spite of having been tortured.
Adrian ordered that he be stretched between four stakes and beaten to death.
And it was in giving thanks under the blows that Saint Leontios gloriously rendered his soul
to God.
Some of the faithful buried his body near the port of Tripoli, where a magnificent basilica
was later built in his honor, to which crowds streamed from all parts to venerate his tomb.
For Saint Leontios became the most honored martyr of Phoenicia and one of the most famous martyrs
in the whole of the Christian East.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord Jesus Christ our God of mercy on us and
save us.